[Music]
the most important exercise that I do
still to this day I would say at least
once a quarter is something called fear
setting and it's intended to help you
overcome or at least analyze the fears
you have so you can take important steps
in different directions start new
projects and projects start
relationships and relationships make
those very seemingly difficult decisions
for which there is no good timing fear
settings when it's called if you want
the full exercise you can go to tim dot
blog forward slash ted I also gave a TED
talk about this you'll see in video
there are four million plus views at
this point and also in text exactly all
the details for how to do this I'm just
going to point out one piece that is I
think under examined and
underappreciated and if you had to pick
just one tiny component of the exercise
perhaps this would be it and that is not
just looking at the costs and risks of
action doing whatever it is you're
considering doing but looking at and
writing down the potential costs of
inaction all right staying still not
changing so if you're considering say
quitting your job you might look at all
of the various worst-case scenarios the
terrible things that could happen and
how to offset that right so you can make
a list defining all of the specific
things that could happen that would be
bad
that would cause you some type of
anxiety depression fear etc whatever it
might be loss what you might do though
instead since that might be very obvious
is to write down a similar list in
detail the specificity is important of
all of the things that it will cost you
all of the things that will happen if
you don't change if you stay in your job
so if you stay for instance in that
relationship if you telescope out and I
recommend telescoping out and doing it
for different time frames alright so in
six months if you don't change anything
what will it cost you make a list in
twelve months what will it cost you what
will it cost the people you care for
make a list right eighteen months three
years you could do those four and just
write down
for you for the people you care for for
others what will it cost if you don't
take that action right and this is very
simply not just looking at the risks and
costs of action but looking at the risks
and costs which are probably in many
ways guaranteed this is not guesswork
and using that as an impetus using that
as a list of reasons to take
uncomfortable action right so that is
one I think under examined piece I would
consider spending time on I certainly
spend time on it at least once a quarter
very often once a month if I'm making a
lot of decisions that caused me
discomfort that I've been putting off
and so on and if you want more detail
just go to Tim Bob log forward slash Ted
and you can run through the entire
exercise
you